hey I'm Tom Mullen and I'm going
undercover on the Internet
it's actually me let's begin first up
let's take ourselves to youtube do you
think that both miles and Peter could
coexist in the same universe or do you
think Peter would have to die first
before they establish miles well I hope
that doesn't happen because I would love
to share the screen with miles I think
that'd be really cool and I don't want
to die because I really love playing
Peter Parker so that would kind of be a
bit of a bummer
how many more spider people are there
same if a karma co-worker posted cancel
to clarify where spider-man's webbing
actually comes from in total wires
version that seems to come from his
actual self but in Tom Hollands version
it is from his web-shooters
yes in Toby's one it comes out of his
wrists he must have like little holes in
his wrists which is kind of gross and in
my one we have web shooters which Tony
Stark made for him and he presses a
little button and it sprays out of his
wrists and and also when he clicks it a
fire horn blows at the back
why is Tom Hollands spider-man shown to
be weaker naive and foolish compared to
Tobey Maguire spider-man hmm because it
makes me more interesting I guess gives
me more room to grow if you start out
about us you could there's nowhere to go
I don't know probably just pissed off a
load of my fans I love Toby's movies
they changed my life growing up did
someone and learn acrobatics before or
after playing spider-man for the first
time I learned acrobatics way before
doing spider-man I did gymnastics from
when I was a little kid in the show
called Billy Elliot and then I just kept
it up while I was just kind of messing
around and then I was lucky enough to
get spider-man and it's been super
helpful how good will Tom Holland be at
playing Batman well I wouldn't be as
good as my friend Robert Pattinson
he's gonna kill it as Batman I don't
even know if that's actually true
is he actually playing Batman he is
that's sick he's gonna kill it
and I wouldn't want to go up against him
because he's a bit of a beast what is
your favorite song roll and roll and why
I have to see spider-man far from home I
think that's my best work I've like
grown a lot as an actor through the
years and I've played lots of different
types of roles but spider-man far from
home was like the first time I got to
play a character who was exploring so
many different crazy things so I'd have
to say that's my best work I'm most
proud of
imagine Deadpool walking up and starting
the bromance we deserve spider-man and
Deadpool spider-man and a Deadpool
series well I can't read I'm just like
sick by the way so this is stressing me
out massively there is already a
bromance between spider-man and Mysterio
and so I wouldn't want to break that out
things are going really strong for space
to do what would you what would we our
stand name miss spider
Mysterio man Spidey Rio up next
Instagram now I know what about
Instagram I like Instagram but I am
gonna delete my Instagram not like get
rid of Mike but I'm gonna delete the app
because I need to take a break from
social media it's taking over my life a
little bit it's going after this
interview I'm gonna do it I hope one day
Tom Holland would have his own TV show
because that would be amazing well you
might have to wait that long
that's it I'm starting off the internet
I hope you enjoyed and learned a little
bit about me hey everybody its charlie
Tom Holland just posted a giant
spider-man video talking about all
things Tobey Maguire future spider-man
films like spider-man for live-action
Miles Morales crossover and Deadpool
crossover so we'll break it all down
there's a new band of that spider-man
far from home blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best live-action Miles
Morales theory on the video just going
down the list number 5 he talks about
doing Miles Morales in the spider-man
movies the new now Sony spider-man's
solo movies because technically he isn't
in the MCU anymore and Marvel isn't
helping them out we just learned that
Sony and Marvel had originally planned
on doing for solo Tom Holland movies
Sony said that they're still doing that
so when we're talking about spider-man 3
in spider-man 4 we temporarily had to
think of them as being Sony movies it
originally in spider-man far from home
they were gonna have miles as uncle
Aaron Davis the Prowler played by Donald
Glover from spider-man homecoming come
back and do a cameo but they cut it out
when it came time to shoot
the movie because there was all this
extra stuff at the beginning with him in
New York City running around it was a
bigger version of the to do list like
they released the extended cut in
theaters with that extra to-do list clip
[Music]
hey Peter Parker here to pick up a
passport please
so during those scenes we would have
seen Aaron Davis come back and even
though he's only on the way to becoming
full-blown prowler from the comics that
would have just been another way to sort
of seed miles along him referencing his
nephew his far as we know timeline Myles
was another one of those people that got
snapped so he's still relatively young
it's not one of those Brad situations
where he's 5 years older so now he's
almost the same age as Peter Parker the
way Tom Holland is talking about the
myles character though makes it sound
like he doesn't want to do a literal
adaptation of ultimate spider-man where
Peter has to die in order for Myles to
be able to take the mantle and become
the spider-man of his earth but based on
what Kevin Feige in the Sony people had
originally said about the art of Peter
Parker spider-man in the MCU is that it
was taking him through high school Harry
Potter style so it was all about him
eventually becoming this fully
actualized version of the character so
number four it seemed like spider-man 3
just supposed to be John wick 3
spider-man him on the next step
Spiderman hunted with Kraven as the main
villain as far as we've heard based on
all the director and producer comments
around spider-man far from home so we
just as a feel like they have room for
live action Miles Morales right now
without it feeling like they're severely
shoehorning him into the universe but
they can totally work up to introducing
him in a big way sometime during
spider-man 4 and then if everything
works out developed that spin-off
trilogy and call it ultimate spider-man
or live-action spider-man into the
spider verse because Amy Pascal did say
they were considering doing a
live-action spider-man into the spider
verse eventually but first you have to
introduce live-action Miles Morales then
Sony can actually do spider verse with
Tom Holland and whoever they get to play
miles and it's an opportunity to bring
back Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
if they really want to go for that this
seems like it's so far off though that's
why I'm not planning on them even
attempting something like that till
after spider-man for whatever that
fourth film winds up being whether it's
sinister six or it winds up being their
big spider-man venom crossover three he
compares his version of spider-man to
Tobey Maguire spider-man this probably
pissed off a lot of Tobey Maguire stands
he's a big fan of those classic
spider-man films just as much as anyone
but still asserts that his
her man is superior because he has more
room to grow that's always subjective
but when you go back and you rewatch
those toby movies he really was playing
a much older version of the character
like a 30-something looking actor
playing a 20-something Peter Parker as
opposed to teenage Peter Parker Tom
Holland and unless there's a giant time
jump between spider-man far from home in
the beginning of spider-man 3 he's still
gonna be a teenager during spider-man 3
to love all the Robert Pattinson Batman
shout outs I've included part of that
clip in my Batman movie video yesterday
I didn't realize they were actually
friends in real life but it would be
funny to see them both show up in a DC
movie together even though that will
never ever happen some of you were even
fan casting Tom Holland as his Robin I
think he's a little too old for Dick
Grayson Robin but that would be
hilarious if they ever turned that into
a Saturday Night Live sketch or
something like that in number one he
jokes about a TV show and crossing over
with Deadpool when he says you might not
have to wait that long to see him on a
TV show he's not necessarily talking
about a spider-man TV show because just
a little while ago we found out that
Lord and Miller are developing
live-action Spiderman TV shows for Sony
that was before the big marvel's Sony
spider-man split and technically I think
that Marvel still holds a lot of the
spider-man TV rights so I don't know how
that's going to affect what Sony's plans
are for live-action spider-verse
in the TV shows because if they can find
the right story the right people to work
on those and the right actors to play
those live-action versions that would be
really badass but we'll get more
information about those TV shows later
this year I think the whole Marvel Sony
split around d23 surprised everyone in
the dust is still settling from that
they haven't come back to the table to
start renegotiating and getting
spider-man back in the MCU so that also
gets into the idea of the Deadpool
crossover that he jokes about before the
big Marvel Sony split I would have said
definitely they share some funny scenes
together in a future Avengers movie
crossover but right now until they bring
spider-man back into the MCU the best
the Deadpool could do would just be
making a ton of spider-man jokes but
because it's gonna be bare minimum at
least four to five years before the next
Avengers movie Avengers 5 Pointz up
dropping they have plenty
time to work out a sharing arrangement
when you look at the Marvel phase 4
schedule
spider-man wasn't gonna be popping up in
any of these other movies anyway so it
wasn't like we were gonna be seeing him
a ton outside of the spider-man solo
films so as bad as it seems right now
things won't be that different than they
were going to be before he technically
left the MCU and because of sony's
recent comments there's still a lot of
questions about that because they did
say that they were continuing the story
the Kevin Feige in the Marvel people set
up in spider-man homecoming and
spider-man far from home so even if they
lose access to some of the a-list
Avengers Marvel characters they'll still
be able to use a lot of the story that
they developed in the MCU spider-man
solo films but post all your spider-man
3 in spider-man 4 theories in the
comments below
and do you actually think that they will
go for live action Miles Morales by
spider-man for Sony really likes setting
up those spin-off franchise movies and
it feels like they would jump at the
chance to do a spin-off franchise with
Miles Morales there's a whole bunch of
other stuff happening this week I'll try
to get to the videos as fast as possible
but leave all your requests and big
questions in the comments below while
you wait for everything click here for
my brand new Marvel phase 4 Fantastic
Four video and click here for that brand
new birds-of-prey
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]